[Music]
hello i'm linda you a warm welcome to
this institute of art and ideas live
event it's my pleasure to host this
debate the next environmental crisis the
new clean energy economy endorsed by
governments and campaigners promises to
save us from environmental disaster but
worries are growing that we could be
heading to a new future crisis in
decades to come some argue we'll be
struggling to contain the huge
environmental damage caused by billions
of highly toxic and unrecyclable solar
cells and car batteries along with newly
commissioned nuclear plants while the
internet itself bitcoin mining included
consumes uncontrollable amounts of
energy are the problems of the
environment even more challenging than
we think will the new economy save us or
are the current technical solutions a
short-term fix
is relentless consumption and growth
itself to blame for environmental issues
where can we rely on humanity's ability
to solve the next crisis that we may be
in the process of causing now huge
questions and to debate all of this i've
got a fantastic panel to do so martin
reese is a fellow of trinity college and
emeritus professor of cosmology and
astrophysics at the university of
cambridge he holds the honorary title of
astronomer royal
judy curry is an american climatologist
and former chair and emeritus professor
of the school of earth and atmospheric
sciences at the georgia institute of
technology thomas sterner is an
economist and a professor of
environmental economics at the
university of gutenberg in sweden
so let's kick off now with three minute
positions from each panelist on the
pitch question
will the new green energy economy
ushered in by governments save us from
environmental disaster
thomas the floor is yours
thank you very much
well i think the jury is out on this one
it remains to be seen
we must first try to get out of climate
change and the um
the cop in glasgow is a little um
depressing the most depressing thing is
perhaps the number it's
number 26
that means that we've been talking about
this for two decades
and
relatively little progress has been made
and
i think that shows
my position is a little intermediate on
them some people are very critical of
what happened so i think that some
progress was made
but
it's a very difficult question and there
are
some
powerful
countries and companies that are doing
what they can to block climate action
and so i think that's
our our first problem to try to and i
think that the
the world has been in a sense lucky that
um wind power and solar power have
actually turned out so far to be
to get cheaper and cheaper and to work
better and better the more we we
energy we put on them
so um
i think we can
we can have some cause for optimism but
i i i definitely think there is a
general tendency for the for the world
economy to create environmental problems
so we need to we need to take seriously
the problems that can be caused in the
future and i think irresponsibly about
recycling programs and
and the like
so that we um so that we do what we can
to minimize future problems thank you
thomas same question to you judy will
the new green energy economy ushered in
by government save us from environmental
disaster the floor is yours in the past
century fossil fuels have been the
backbone of our energy and
transportation systems providing the
engine of our
ever increasing prosperity
even without the mandate associated with
global warming and other environmental
issues we would expect a natural
transition away from fossil fuels as
they become more expensive to extract
and continue to contribute to
geopolitical instability
the problem is with the urgency of the
transition driven by fears about global
warming
by rapidly transitioning to the
so-called clean energy economy we're
taking a big step backwards in human
development and prosperity
nations are coming to grips with their
growing over dependence on wind and
solar energy
concerns about not meeting electricity
needs this winter are resulting in a
near-term reliance on coal in europe and
asia
and we ignore the environmental impacts
of mining and toxic waste from solar
panels and batteries and the destruction
of raptors by wind turbines
to thrive in the 21st century the world
will need much more energy
of course we prefer our energy to be
clean as well as cheap
to get there we need new technologies
the most promising right now is small
modular nuclear reactors but there are
also exciting advances in geothermal
hydrogen and others and the technology
landscape will look different even 10
years from now
for the past two decades people have
equated environmental disaster with
man-made global warming
we've been hearing about the climate
crisis climate catastrophe existential
threat and most recently a code red for
humanity
note that the ipcc reports do not use
the words crisis catastrophe or even
dangerous rather the ipcc uses the term
reasons for concern
apart from the scientific uncertainties
the weakest part of the un's argument
about man-made global warming is that
it's dangerous
the link to danger relies on linking
warming to more extreme weather events
which is a tenuous lincoln best
i have an old-fashioned view of
environmental problems focused on
pollution of air water soils and oceans
and also on land use that destroys
habitats and this diminishes species
diversity
in 50 years time we may be looking back
on the un climate policies as using
chemotherapy to try to cure a head cold
all the while ignoring more serious
diseases
in other words the climate crisis
gets in the way of real solutions to our
societal and environmental problems
thank you judy martin reese the floor
i think when we talk about we and us in
this context it makes a big difference
whether we're thinking of the prosperous
north where we are sitting
or the global south
we in the north uh can quite plausibly
um
use much less energy we do now
use it much cleaner etc
but if you're in india or africa
when you're currently using energy at a
far lower rate probably at least five
times less than the average citizen of
europe or north america then of course
uh it's a big ask to say that you should
abandon the cheapest form of energy now
which is normally coal
but and move to something else
so i think that we've got to accept
that the global south which by 2050 is
going to be four
billion people
are going to need more energy per capita
and
unless there are huge breakthroughs in
technology
they're going to get a lot of that at
least all the base load
from something like coal
so my feeling is that what we've got to
do really is to accelerate the certain
development in the hope
that we can develop some
form of carbon-free
clean energy
which can be
used
by india
affordably
it gets as cheap as coal
that's not
on the horizon yet
but maybe
as judah said small modular nuclear
reactors could achieve this
we've got to do that if we want to avoid
climate change
which of course gets more serious
after 2050.
just one point about climate change
it's not a catastrophe in the short run
but it's something which
could
leave a dangerous legacy for our
descendants
and what we need to worry about more is
not the most likely scenario but the
worst
five percent
of the probability curve which could be
catastrophic and so as an insurance
against that
we surely ought to uh do what we can to
reduce our carbon emissions but overall
the problem is that we got by 2050
the prospect of about 9 billion people
on this planet
global food production will have to be
doubled if they are all to be fed as
well as we are in the north now and the
great risk is to do this in a way that
destroys the environment and disturbs
the balance thank you thank you martin
um
there's quite a lot of points we can get
into on the back of
the back of your opening um
statement i think the first thing that
we'll try and explore is this question
to continue watching this video click
the link in the top left or in the
description below or visit iai.tv for
more debates and talks from the world's
leading thinkers on today's biggest
ideas
you